σίγουρα η μετάβαση μου στην αθήνα αφού είχα εξασφάληση το όριο γιο του ο υμπιακούς
αγόνες το έσερα όμως όταν πήκαν στην αθήνα και γνωριμία μου τότε με τον προπονητή
μου το δημήτ των ευθυμείου τότε επίστεψα ότι απλά δεν θέλω να έχου μια φάνηση
θέλω να έχω μια διάκριση ποιος σο έβαλε αυτό το μικρόβιο για το άλμα εσύψωςείναι
όλα πολύ τυχέα να το πω έτσι πιο καθαρά δεν μου έβαλε κανέές δεν ήξερα
κάτη ίναν ο αλμα εσύψως όλι ός καταλαβαίνεις νωρίζαε ετι ήταν το ποδόσφερο τον πάσκε
κύριο στοτο κοδόσφερο οπότε ότους άλλος σήμους σε ακατημιες τοπ τοσφέρου όμως σε μαθητικούς αγόνες
αλλού προωριζόμου να δηαδή στα εμπόδια και τότε ο γυμναστίς μου χρήσος ομογαλεκκήδης ο δάσκαλος
δεν ε δενημουν γλήωρος ψητουσα πολύ περισσότερο πιο ψηλά τα εμπόδια παρά ότι έπρεπε για
να τερματήσω και την ημέρα που ήταν οι υπαρχειακί αγώνε η δύο μέρες πριν το
παιδί που ήταν να λάβει μέρος τους σοάλομε εσύψως είχε νααρωστήσει και ήταν πιο εύκολο
να βρει κάποιο να τρέξει εμπόδια ποιο τι σκολο να ρει κάποιος το άλμα εσύψως
κάνα μια προπόνη ση θυμα μου έδειξενο ο δάσκαλος μπήκα και έτσιέμαθα τίνει το άλμα
εσύψως από ίκαι πέρα μου καν η διαίτερη έίσθηση γιατί είναιιδιαίτερο ναθλημα το το άλμα
εσύψως θυμάμε πρότοσμα αγόνα σε είθα κάναμει ένακσπέντε και ήθελα να δω κατά πόσο ρώ
να πιδείξω ψηλότερα τουλάχισον και από το σωματικό μου ύψως και αυτό τον διαφέρο σιγά
σιγά έγινε το άνθρημα που αγάπη σα περισσότερο καιεπαγγελμα ένα κεφάλεο το δαμε και με
τον πάύλο κοντίδι που πέρασε απά αυτό το πότκας είναι η επαγγελματική αποκατάσταση το συζήσανε
τον πάύλο οποιος ακόμη εία είνανεργός αθλητής άρα το έχει στο πίσω μέρος του μι
άλλο του εσύ που έχει σταματήσει